the last two years has annihilated any
sense of trust i have not only in
mainstream media but also in
institutions and the powers that be it's
just a really lethal cocktail of neglect
malice and incompetence but is there
still a swath of people that have faith
it seems to me that the older generation
that is more skeptical of the
institutions at the moment the sort of
radicalized boomers who are voting for
brexit and trump who are just like you
know what no this is god bless they're
the ones who did the right thing the
problem i have are the zoomers
millennials who don't know any different
and don't have any framework for
legitimacy outside of the power of the
state and the institution this is the
worst thing about intersectionality
having proliferated through our schools
and through our cultures and through our
institutions i've had to have these
conversations with my 11 year old
daughter where she's come home but like
i think i'm bi oh well i'm really
worried you know i'm part of the lgbt
community i'm really worried about
transphobia she's 11. this is not
something that we can take lightly one
problem that we have is that the entire
thing is based on the worship of power